y sergio massa juramento como
superministro de economía en argentina
un país con muchos problemas en esta
materia vamos a ver más detalles de esta
información con mejor resultado que nos
acompaña aquí en el estudio bueno sergio
massa asume como ministro de economía
jorge bueno no solamente economía
también de desarrollo productivo y
agricultura es el segundo nombrado en
menos de un mes más el confirmó que tuvo
ya su primera reunión con el fondo
monetario internacional para honrar el
acuerdo de refinanciación de deuda dijo
que el gobierno no utilizará los
anticipos del tesoro en lo que queda de
este año que también buscará cómo
sostener el superávit comercial el
fortalecimiento de la reserva y que eran
las correcciones necesarias para cumplir
precisamente este acuerdo con él efe fm
también anunció la creación de un
sistema de trazabilidad para el comercio
exterior con un mayor control a divisas
para importaciones el nuevo ministro
dijo que argentina espera un desembolso
de 1.200 millones de dólares y otro de
750 millones con organismos
internacionales próximamente además
podría dar una cuota de oxígeno al
gobierno de alberto fernández que de la
renuncia de martín guzmán como titular
del ministerio de economía todavía no
consigue contener la crisis cambiaria ni
la economía que escuchamos un poco lo
que decía el nuevo primer ministro
en cuanto a los principios orden fiscal
superávit comercial
fortalecimiento de reservas y desarrollo
con inclusión en cuanto a los motores de
inversión producción importaciones y
defensa del mercado interno
las medidas que
vamos a seguir en la región de américa
latina por qué lado se demostró un
aumento de la inflación en los países
que integran este grupo internacional de
hecho santiago los precios de la energía
y alimentos de junio fueron los más
altos en 34 años en junio de la
inflación anual del organismo llegó al
10,3 por ciento frente al 9 7%
registrado en mayo en la región chile y
costa rica mostraron los mayores
aumentos aunque fueron seguidos también
por países como colombia y méxico para
la unión europea la ocde reportó una
inflación anual en junio del 96 por
ciento y para eeuu del 9,1 por ciento
hablemos ahora de venezuela que están
allí viendo la posibilidad de reactivar
un gasoducto abandonado que conecta a
este país con la vecina colombia que
según una publicación del diario
bloomberg petróleos de venezuela
pedevesa controlada por el estado espera
reanudar este gasoducto de 139 millas
aprovechando la normalización de
relaciones como el nuevo gobierno de
gustavo petro en colombia la información
la confirmó juan ricardo ortega director
de una de las mayores energéticas de
colombia la reapertura de los productos
transcaribeño antonio ricaurte podría
ayudar a venezuela a recuperarse de su
crisis económica y reducir el riesgo de
escasez de gas en colombia para el año
2025 2026 venezuela tiene unos 197
billones de pies cúbicos de reservas
probadas de gas natural es la octava
mayor cantidad del mundo así como los
mayores depósitos de crudo del planeta
el proyecto podría marcar el reinicio de
los lazos energéticos entre bogotá y
caracas jorge reporta vamos en el bloque
de noticias que el barco razón y ya va
navegando hacia el puerto de trípoli en
el líbano es el primer barco que zarpe
con granos ucranianos que sigue ahora
entonces bueno ucrania afirma que tiene
17 buques más cargados de productos
agrícolas a la espera del aporte de la
aprobación para zarpar este primer barco
salió de la zona en conflicto después de
que turquía y naciones unidas- negociar
en el mes pasado un acuerdo de
exportación de cereales y fertilizantes
entre moscú y kiev un funcionario
aseguró que podrían salir tres barcos
diarios desde cualquiera de los tres
puertos del mar negro y también ahora
este acuerdo de 120 días se va a
prorrogar un mes si las exportaciones no
se completan debido a las condiciones
metereológicas o también a problemas con
estas inspecciones a las que tienen que
pasar las embarcaciones ucrania
exportaba entre 5 y 6 millones de
toneladas de granos al mes a través de
sus puertos marítimos antes de la guerra
pero volver a esa cifra el corto plazo
no es realista dicen los expertos y para
el cierre de esta bloque de noticias
pasamos a hablar de la organización de
naciones unidades que presentó un
informe con propuestas para responder a
la actual crisis energética si se le
puede considerar crisis energética bueno
el organismo pidió a los países con
mayores medidas para este ahorro
energético como limitar el uso del aire
acondicionado y la calefacción así como
cambios en el sistema de transporte a
nivel global el informe propone toda una
serie de medidas a corto mediano y largo
plazo dan como ejemplo que la
calefacción supuso en 2021 el 50 por
ciento del consumo final de energía a
nivel global por lo que estas medidas
pueden tener un enorme impacto el
secretario general de naciones unidas
antonio gutiérrez señaló a las grandes
compañías petroleras de lucrarse en
momentos de crisis escuchamos que decía
first it is more es inmoral que las
empresas de petróleo y gas estén
obteniendo beneficios récord de esta
crisis energética a costa de las
personas y comunidades más pobres y con
un coste masivo para el clima instó a
todos los gobiernos a grabar estos
beneficios excesivos ya utilizar los
fondos para apoyar a las personas más
vulnerables y en estos tiempos difíciles
este soporte the most powerful people to
this dificulta jms dejamos de lado las
noticias económicas cifra el día para el
cierre 70% eso aumentó la filmación de
series en méxico en la última década
mientras que la producción de
largometrajes tocó un récord de 250 por
año según la cámara nacional de
industria cinematográfica de ese país
muchas gracias jorge por este dato del
cierre es todo por el momento en la
economía en directo américa a
continuación el debate
[Música]